I don't know rented that movie uh pride
recently if you guys seen that movie let
me see that it's about the first
all-black swim team and the difficulties
they had to go through being the first
all-black swim team a major question how
many of those white people are evil
movies are they gonna make it's like
it's all the way down to swimming you
know I'm starting to run out of white
kilts you know now let's take those
movies they started off unbelievable
start off with roots right white guilt
was at an all-time high I could barely
even watch it I'm like dude I got it my
ancestors evil okay please please turn
the channel dude please turn the channel
they still hit them [ __ ] turn the
channel this is gonna be on all week
Jesus Christ for the king they're the
80s it was like a football movie then
like Cuba Gooding want to be like a
scuba diver I remember that [ __ ]
and now it's all the way down to
swimming and I gotta admit I don't think
I give a [ __ ]
I'm not trying to be a dick but it's a
recreational activity plus I've been in
pools there's been black people in the
pool you know I never saw any white guy
like trying to like [ __ ] like prevent
people from getting into the pool thing
they just like making this [ __ ] up
I'm not being a dick here either
okay just to clarify you know I just
want anybody coming up to me after the
show line you know I was thinking it
then you [ __ ] said it I'm not saying
that I'll pick jack [ __ ] people should
be loud put on some speedos and go for a
dip I'm not saying that [ __ ] I'm just
saying these movies he's like the
characters aren't even believable like
they always have to have like that
though the over-the-top uninhibited
white racist character you know know
that guy he's a guy like he's supposed
to represent all the white evil you know
he's like the dude they always have like
screaming during the movie trailer
they'll be like they were the first
all-black swim team a big vein in his
forehead is screaming [ __ ] look not even
looking around you know dude it's
ridiculous real racism is quiet it's
subtle people look around first make
sure that you know they make sure the
coast is clear
there's disclaimers like dude you know
I'm not racist but these insert group
name followed by [ __ ] up conversation
right that's how it goes down just some
guy just standing up over this I work at
the bank but I'd be fired immediately
please I'm just saying can you just make
the [ __ ] like believable
you know the honest thing is those
movies they're starting to give me a
complex you know cuz any time they do a
movie about a group of people that
thinks dumb [ __ ] about another group of
people it's always like white dudes so
it's like a white dudes the only ones
who think ignorant [ __ ] about other
people you know no Mexican guy ever
walked up to somebody from India like
dude what the [ __ ] is that
[ __ ] you fight to ceiling was walking
around well you guys don't eat cows you
bunch of banks
then why are you wearing sandals good
sandal special back
[Applause]
I'm just saying you know just balance
the movies out a little bit like just
have some of the evil [ __ ] that black
people say about white people you know
when we're not around you know like like
what are some good examples you know I
mean you're hanging out we had a rough
day you know what are some of the
classics you know what smell like wet
dogs right you got headlights or
something like that right just just slip
some of that [ __ ] in there get out of
the pool wash your hand with a [ __ ]
friend just make it seem a little more
dude I'm just saying it's all the way
down to swimming and where the [ __ ] do
you go from there we do like ping pong
they were the first all-black ping pong
team they're gonna steal the paddle
my daughter's not playing ping-pong you
got to go out there and show the white
man your baby ping-pong
racism everywhere everybody pissed off
black people yelling racism white people
yelling reverse racism Chinese people
yelling sideways very civil in the
Indians and yelling [ __ ] cuz they did so
everybody [ __ ] about how bad they
people got a nobody got it worse than
the American Indian everybody need to
calm the [ __ ] down Indians got it bad
and he's got it the works you know how
bad the Indians got it was the last time
you met two Indians
you ain't never met two innings [ __ ] I
haven't seen a polar bear out of [ __ ]
tricycles in my lifetime I have never
seen an Indian family just chilling out
at Red Lobster
never seen it
everybody want to save the environment
should I see trees every [ __ ] day
I'll never see no Indians I look to the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade this year
they don't even have enough Indian sir
that [ __ ] and a bunch of pilgrims when
it came time for the Indians and three
real Indians and the rest of the bunch
of border Ricans with feathers in their
head
oh [ __ ] I know Puerto Ricans when I see
him you can't slip a porter rincon by me
Pocahontas Jennifer Lopez I went down
south with America recently and there's
this white lady that's like working well
she's taking us all over the place and
showing us things and the first thing
she says to me she goes hey che I don't
want to sell racist or anything which is
always the best way to start a
conversation so I want to sound racist
anything you've got to try this chicken
restaurant down the block it's amazing
like why would that be racist well you
know cuz you're black you're like which
is oh that's one of those stereotypes
that's like true and black people we
really don't know how to respond to it
it's uncomfortable and I don't know why
we're hiding what's wrong with like a
chicken a lot is that strange is chicken
an odd thing are we the only ones let's
just say for instance just for
argument's sake that black people love
chicken more than any other race on the
planet you got us you figured it out you
cracked the [ __ ] collar why is that
I'm asking because it was a guy that
made the news they were Sergio Garcia
he's a golfer and he told Tiger Woods he
said I'm gonna make Tiger Woods some
fried chicken at my house and the whole
country said dad's racist and I'm like
is it what kind of thoughtful ass racist
finds out your favorite food
and then threatens to make it for you as
damn near hospitable I live in New York
City so I don't know how people could be
racist diversity is what makes things
special I love you I love cultures you
can't hate me you need me I'm black I
make [ __ ] cool and we need white people
because you makes you safe and we all
need Asian people because they make sure
affordable
[Applause]
now I probably got some other group
pissed off of me because I said fruit
there's a different group to get pissed
off at you in this country for
everything you're not supposed to say
can't say fruit can't say [ __ ] can't
say queer can't say Nancy boy can't say
pansy can't say [ __ ] boogie jig
[ __ ] skinhead jungle bunny Morley
Mullen Jana shot sir can't say Yid heeds
e-type machi [ __ ] Guinea [ __ ] Jinzo
greaser [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh a
tiger PR Mik donkey Turkey limey frog
Squarehead kraut jerry hun [ __ ] jack
nip slope slope and zip zipper head dude
there is absolutely nothing wrong there
is absolutely nothing wrong with any of
those words in and of themselves they're
only words it's the context that counts
it's the user it's the intention behind
the words that makes them good or bad
the words are completely neutral the
words are innocent I get tired of people
talking about bad words and bad language
[ __ ] it's the context that makes
them good or bad the context
that makes them get there Princeton you
take the word [ __ ] there is absolutely
nothing wrong with the word [ __ ] in
and of itself it's the racist [ __ ]
who's using it that you ought to be
concerned about we don't care what
Richard Pryor or Eddie Murphy say it why
because we know they're not racist
they're [ __ ] I find a lot of that a
lot of that racial stuff like
fascinating you know like the different
rules of like how who gets in trouble
who doesn't like I noticed black people
have the genius to put the curse word
after they say the race of the person
where white dudes we always put it in
front and if we would just make that
little adjustment we could save so many
careers so many cheap ups could be saved
in the white community if we would just
put it after you never noticed that in
conversation here a black everything
like man I was standing in this Asian
[ __ ] came in he starts talking
about you don't even hear him
what did this asian mom [ __ ] dope i
would love to hear the rest of this
story right don't I would tell the exact
same story right I'm standing there
right this [ __ ] agent I just said
what he said I just preempted the [ __ ]
that's all I did
he'd suggest that he's hooking up with
people's mothers I'm not even doing that
I got it out of the way I got it out of
the way that's how I caught this [ __ ]
guy came in [ __ ] Asian dude are you
wearing sandals Jesus Christ oh my god
sandals with middle of December yeah you
want all those people man my feet don't
get cold you know this place that one
got big ski Parker and shorts and my leg
my leg though kickball thanks okay come
that's like his only hope of hooking up
with somebody like maybe that's
interesting to mate with that'll make a
strong baby his legs don't get cold I
don't know what it is plenty of blood
for the organs
that had nothing to do with you that had
to do with me being on the road for four
months
that's all this